bonsoir cécile bonjour à tous je suis
très heureux et très ému ce soir d'être
nommé pour le césar de meilleur homme
étant maintenant d'être nommé pour le
concombre est demandé d'être mettant
c'est un peu l'accomplissement de toute
une carrière
j'ai énormément travaillé pour ça enfant
déjà j'ai beaucoup remis au lendemain
ce que je pouvais faire aujourd'hui et
aujourd'hui me voilà voilà voilà
qu'est ce qu'on fait là maintenant et et
ben vas-y
oui il faut faut d'abord qu'elles
viennent qu'elle vienne me chercher
scarlett johansson c'est à dire ah ben
c'est à dire que je suis sénat césar
d'honneur je suis donneur de césar donc
je suis césar d'honneur
donc la question c'est qui me remet à
scarlett
non non non non non à escalettes on lui
remet un césar d'honneur en deux mots
toiture mais le césar du meilleur décor
si tu veux bien avant justement le plus
beau décor c'est celui de scarlett
non mais c'est ça aussi le cinéma des
corps galbé les corps musclé décor on
fait ça c'est plutôt dans le nord
non c'est fn décor en un mot ah oui
c'est ça hockey amh choses sérieuses car
le hockey
vous avez beau dire venaille the winner
is not personal and french cinema pas je
ne comprends pas c'est pourtant les
oiseaux augure present fawer futur ça si
jamais on veut enfin bon ramadan à
présent le césar du meilleur son je
pensais qu'on remettait le césar du
meilleur son c'est ce que je viens de
dire pas entendu
effectivement remettons à présent wouah
demain pour ceux qui ont le courage de
revenir le césar du meilleur son car
bien que le cinéma soit souvent une
affaire de blé
on ne peut nier l'importance du son et
de céréales qui nous ouvre les portes du
cinéma parlant et quinoa ainsi de
poisson s'est fait fait simple s'il te
plaît mais c'est ce que j'étais en train
de faire
oui alors fait plus court c'est dommage
parce qu'après j'envoyais sur un truc
vachement subtil avec oui mais les
chansons français pourquoi pas si non à
des prochaines peut-être la bonne idée
ok